hey guys dog walker here um well you
probably just saw my bum review so now
you probably want to see what I really
thought the movie um well first of all
should probably know this movies getting
like mad praise I mean has like what 97
percent on Rotten Tomatoes yeah a lot of
movies do this weekend you got this you
got Hugo Arthur Christmas I mean these
are like three big family films are
getting like just great reviews and yet
Breaking Dawn is probably gonna beat all
of them so shows you where our values
live anyway that's another subject I
should talk about the Muppets here if
I'm gonna talk about it's the next in
the whatever umpteenth movie series so I
guess I should talk about just really
briefly what I thought the other ones so
you can compare and contrast okay first
of all was that the Muppet movie I had
Milton Berle and of course the Muppets
and in it and I really liked it I liked
a lobby and jokes especially back then I
think that was like 70s if not early 80s
and for them to do so many in jokes in
this movie and start making a roadtrip
movie it was really cool and I really
liked it
the next one is the great Muppet Caper
and that was my favorite that one I
think had the best jokes and a really
funny story the fourth wall jokes were
right on top of each other and it was
just a lot of fun so I really liked that
one was after that Muppets Take
Manhattan uh I liked as a kid I don't
like now I don't think it really holds
it up I think it's really awkward if you
watch it again it's like some of the
songs are good at seeing where they you
know the same goodbye I mean that's
depressing as hell that's like the
saddest that's ever gotten in a Muppet
movie though wait but I just thought it
didn't hold up very well it's sort of a
glorifying itself kind of movie which I
don't want to see the Muppets do I like
when they're awkward you know just
having fun with things I mean not when
they're intentionally awkward I should
say okay what was after that was that
was that Muppet Christmas Carol I think
those Muppet Christmas Carol uh which is
okay um I think it really did a good job
hooking kids in because that's the first
like kiddie Christmas Carol that kids
can watch and so that's like that's the
first one a lot kids watch so they have
you now they have you by the balls huh
you know now they're up there with
Disney it's like Muppets are one of the
first things you ever see so it was very
clever do Christmas Carol um I thought
was okay there are some things are
pretty clever but
I don't think it's good like Muppet
Caper the first one then you have Muppet
church Ryan which I finally saw again
okay
L is alright except for Tim Curry who as
far as I'm concerned has a pass on any
movie now he can do no wrong
I am totally convinced he is a
live-action Muppet you can just see
someone putting the hand up there just
say like you know do you have Prince
Albert in a can
I mean it's he's a muppet that's why
he's so entertaining um so it it was
okay you know blah boring spots but Tim
curry made up for it I never saw Muppets
in space but I hear it's really bad I
hear that's the one I was like the nail
in the coffin for the Muppets and then
they started doing these TV movies which
I saw one or two I saw there's some it
was a Christmas moment Whoopi Goldberg
that that was shown to me and I don't
remember what was called I had some
really funny jokes but it's try to get a
little too adult a little too aware of
itself and it was really distracting and
then the Muppets just sorta disappeared
for a while and they don't appear once a
while in a commercial or something but
for the most part they were pretty much
dead and then also in this revival comes
with this incredible marketing just this
friggin ingenious marketing and they've
been doing videos on YouTube even before
the movie was coming out they had the
whole Bohemian Rhapsody and just these
great little songs that they've been
doing and they're just huge hits and
they're very funny
so that will they caught on and now
they've been doing this movie written by
Anna Jason Segel who little stars in it
and then somebody else wrote it - I'm
sorry - whoever that writer is because I
don't remember the name and honestly I
really really like this movie I'm right
up there with all the people praising it
it's very much like the first to Muppet
movies and everything I like about the
first two month at movies though this
one adds something else this adds
something that the other Muppet movies
were trying to give but they never quite
got except for maybe that saying goodbye
song is that there's a lot of heart to
this movie and let me tell you know the
Muppets disappear for a while and
they'll be watching and stuff I did you
will feel like an asshole watching this
movie and you would I was just like I'm
sorry I never saw Muppets his face it
looked
I still love you guys you do have to go
and they really play up the emotion in
this and they do it very well and it's
very effective there's a great scene
where Kermit's locking eyes look at all
the old pictures of of the Muppets and
what they used to be and then the
pictures start singing to him they start
coming alive it's very sentimental and
it's very smart uh the jokes are also
very very good that of course there's a
lot of worthwhile jokes eleven you've
seen before but the reworked enough just
you know so that they pass by like
there's a scene where we see Kermit for
the first time there's a light and a
heavenly choir and then we back up it
turns out you know the lights coming
from a bus and the choirs actuate the
singing choir on the bus know Brooks did
that and the Simpsons did that but it
still works here you know it's not
overuse it and they tweaked it a little
bit there's a lot of jokes like that a
lot of these jokes you will find
familiar but they still work and they
work because it's these characters doing
it and you like seeing these characters
do it and they do add sort of a new
twist on it
so what else what else the plot is you
probably hear it's about a little Muppet
again on how to do next work but this
little Muppet named Walter wants to go
to the Muppet Studios to see it one last
time and the studio is in shambles and
they have to and this evil oil tycoon
played for laughs keep in mind if you're
gonna hear that's like what that sounds
- but no it's played for laughs Chris
Cooper comes in as oil tycoon who's
going to take over the muppet studio and
drill for a while I mean there's even
the zebra empties then Todd you keep
just goes with maniacal laugh maniacal
laugh I guess the art people laugh with
it they're playing it for fine so don't
take it too seriously
um and so they go to Kermit and yes we
got to get the rest of them others
together so they can save the Muppets
studio and the whole film is about them
trying to do that a way a lot of it
works that the people are actually
pretty entertaining
even before the Muppets come on I was
really entertained by just the way
they're telling this story they have
these over-the-top musical numbers that
are just really really silly and really
in your face but they're impressive but
really impressive especially with them
up it in there as well so that stuff's
all really
good in terms of problem the problems I
have are very nitpicky but I do have a
few one is that there may be one or two
too many songs too many notes No
Amadeus joke so they go out and they
perform you know a lot of these songs a
lot of them are good there's one cold
are you a man or a muppet I mean it's
very funny the opening song is very
funny my mother's - there's one where
Amy Adams and I think this piggy sing a
song it's like it's something like out
for one or dinner for one or something
like I can't remember and it's so short
and so rushed you just didn't see the
purpose that you could cut that and be
fine it's the same thing there's a song
Chris Cooper sings like a money rap you
know that would be fine if there was a
purpose for it or even a you know this
is like the fifth song to come out of
nowhere and just leave just as quickly
and and they do make a joke about but I
don't know if it was worth I think you
very easily could chop that but that's
that's nitpicking and they're very short
and you know there's still a few laughs
in it in him anyway
I was gonna complain about some of the
celebrities not being used effectively
enough but you know what that's all them
up in movies the only ones where they
really they really utilize the
celebrities actually were the Treasure
Island and the the Christmas Carol would
have won big celebrity you know Tim
Curry and Michael Caine and they were
one of the big stars all the other
mother films just walk by celebrities
and stuff like that but really angry
because I saw Sarah Silverman I love
Sarah Silverman think oh what's gonna
happen she has like one line gone I was
like I really I really wanted to see her
do something with the Muppets but you
know what can you do I get that's I
serve them up a formula so you go along
with it I would like maybe if they
changed it a bit um what else okay
there's one thing that really by they're
not gonna totally ruin what it is if you
saw the bumper people you already know
it is but they're building up this
ending big time this really wants a
really adult really mature ending it's a
kind of ending I want to see actually in
more family films or especially kids
films where it looks like what they were
shooting for it didn't get accomplished
and that despite that they're gonna move
on they're still going to be strong
there is a family you know and they
really make I mean think about a lot of
time to us I me this is like five
minutes you know five to ten days just
talking about what happened here and how
they're gonna live within how they're
still going to survive and they're gonna
be strong and stuff like that then they
go outside and there's a big reveal and
you know it's I was like whoa is this
movie really doing this us this this is
ballsy this is really ballsy but really
smart really adult wow this is like
taking this to a whole new level that a
muppet movies never done before you know
this is really really you know
intelligent and civilized and smart and
and still heartfelt and caring and I was
really blown away by it even says the
end I went wow they really did this
credits start don't know we're not doing
that ah total cop-out oral friggin cava
I was so angry at that because I really
thought I mean okay it's a muffin boy
yeah all the time
my brother's wife about this and she's
like you know you gotta go in knowing
it's a muppet movie in like I know but
when you build up that you're going to
take it to a new level and then you
don't and now they do you not but it's a
very last minute you know snap no we're
doing this while the credits are rolling
mind you that really let me down I
thought this was really gonna go to a
whole new level and and it didn't quite
you know but if you're you're gonna do
that do it all the way come on you know
so that that really disappointed me but
that's more just what it what it could
have been you know um but for what it is
it's great it's really funny and it's
really the Muppet it at reminds me a lot
of I don't gonna out about this but the
new link Tunes cartoon you know that I
think it's you know it's sort of a
different set of different scenario but
it's still these same characters I mean
I just love these characters I love
seeing them interact with various things
especially new things you know things
that you know they've been around for a
while so now they can comment on and it
it cracked me up I thought it was great
I thought was very sentimental when to
get to the Rainbow Connection I mean
everyone the audience is like oh I mean
there's like four or five cry scenes in
this movie and they they're effective
they really work so yeah
I really loved it I thought it was a lot
of fun I thought was very smart I felt
this just like the Muppets I grew up
with just like the first two Muppet
films and I'm just I'm all over it I
thought was great I loved to see a
sequel though I don't know what they
would do it very interesting to see what
they do for a sequel because I don't
think they can do like another whatever
in our Christmas Carol like the Headless
Horseman for Halloween you know they
have to really think of something to you
know either continue the story or top it
or just do something really different so
I mean curious to see what they come up
with because chances are this is gonna
be a big hit I mean they've marketed you
know they've advertised it like mad I
don't think I don't know if it's gonna
be Breaking Dawn because the the crowd
for that is just so determined and
chances are my rant has probably
influenced so many more people because
ironically so um but it's gonna be a big
hit and chances are they will be open
for a sequel or something maybe they'll
do another show who knows so I really
loved it I'm really glass on if you like
the Muppets
you'll love this people I guess people
who wouldn't like it um I guess if you
don't like because you know Muppets if
you don't like if you think there's sort
of you know debate pop cultural jokes or
to maybe fourth wall jokes or something
like that there's a lot here there's a
lot of heart too but if you were never
into them up it's chances are you won't
get into it here either
um how my tip this might be the deal
changer no I don't think it would be if
you don't like the Muppets you're not
gonna like it here probably not because
it is a lot just it's a lot of the same
old characters just you know with the
serve a much better story so yeah
hopefully you can gather whether or not
you would enjoy those or not and I shall
talk to you later